well what's exciting for me is this is
the first time i get to watch the film
with an audience
we've only had um three screenings where
the filmmakers have been able to be
present the first was at the sundance
film festival in january of 2020 and i
was in morocco shooting inventing anna
and then the pandemic happened and we
released our film during
um the pandemic and so we
really missed out on getting to be in a
room and there's something very special
about a film that you've been involved
in making and being in the room with an
audience watching it and i haven't
gotten to experience that so i'm really
excited to be in a room full of people
watching the film for the first time do
you know that feeling when you're
sitting in a movie theater and
everyone's laughing at something and you
just don't get it
[Music]
i hate everyone else in the world but
you i never thought i'd live in a world
where trans people would be celebrated
i'm incredibly proud of the film because
everyone that we speak to on camera is
trans themselves and they bring their
they work in the industry and they bring
their own lived experiences as as
filmmakers as actors and what has been
so beautiful for me over the past two
years since the film has been released
is hearing from people who didn't
understand the extent of media
indoctrination
that has
caused them to have so much
misinformation so many misconceptions
about who trans people are you thank you
so much for this moment i never thought
the media would stop asking horrible
questions how do you hide your peanuts
and start treating us with respect i've
never felt safe as a trans person i mean
and celebrity certainly has not um made
me feel more safe
i wish it did um that would be lovely
but it hasn't unfortunately
reality my lived experience has shown me
that
celebrity doesn't shield me from
violence as a trans person allowing the
audience to understand deeply the ways
in which media has shaped the ways in
which they think about trans people how
we think about ourselves and how those
representations have not been
accurate have not been empowering have
not been
um reflective of the
humanity and multi-dimensionality of
trans real trans lives